all right there's your divisional
bracket four games this weekend and they
all should be excellent entertaining
games although chris i gotta tell you
after having six
in super wild card weekend is there a
way we can have two more i don't know
how to do it a couple of consolation
games i don't know i want six again i
like that three windows per day saturday
and sunday but we'll have two windows
saturday two windows sunday and before
we close the book on super wild card
weekend we have to give out our awards
goats in a bad way
since there is no trivia question today
i will just go ahead and give you the
first pick since you were right about
nick saban being i do have a trivia
question
oh okay good i didn't say there's no
i've got nothing here all right go ahead
all right here we go is it a nick saban
trivia question yes uh is he the
greatest college coach of all time yes
is he one of the greatest coaches of all
time yes oh you got that wrong sorry i'm
fair i'm first okay here we go taylor
heineke became the second washington qb
with a passing touchdown and a rushing
touchdown and a playoff game who was the
other
rushing touchdown
throwing touchdown playoff game brad
johnson brad johnson
it's uh
mr prime time himself but a court of
cousin so you're the favorite
quarterback yeah
i knew there was some i knew there was a
minnesota connection i just went too far
back in time i don't even know that brad
johnson played in a playoff game i think
he did in 99. he did we saw the other
night he was there in washington against
coach dungey in that crazy game so yes
all right
um
gonna go with someone that i got a lot
of respect for here but i don't think
had necessarily his best day as far as
managing a game i'm gonna go with frank
reich as my first pick you know two
reasons you know one hey yes i didn't
love the fourth and goal decision to
throw it there up ten to seven you know
your defense everything's playing well
at that point go up 13 to seven on the
road uh i will blame philip rivers there
for fading away for no reason to on that
throw he deserves a little of that if he
just stepped up it's gonna be an easy
throw for some reason he faded away um
but between that and then i'll tell you
here here's the one that kind of got
swept under the radar because of all the
craziness of that game
had a really bad challenge
what what did i say
what did i say
he said swept under the radar oh
i like that actually we got two we got
two in one day go ahead
see that's really sweeping it that's
really that's like really
under under
the radar either way
i think i think
the zack moss you remember this play
mike where he got he fumbled
but he didn't fumble he was hurt he was
laying on the ground somebody stripped
the ball out frank wright challenged it
and they lost the time out because of it
and guess what happened the colts got on
fringe tel field goal territory and had
no timeouts had to throw the ball
towards the sidelines of course the
buffalo bills knew that and they could
never get closer to actually kick the
field goal because they missed that time
out so because of that i'll i'll pick
frank reich who had a a really damn good
year but uh had some bad moments on
saturday
hey look that fourth down play if it
works he's a genius and maybe they win
the game but he went all in when you go
all in
and you don't have the cards you got to
deal with the aftermath of having gone
all in i i got to start with
a guy and i can't believe i'm saying
this because he had 13 catches for 157
yards and a touchdown how can he be a
goat he's a goat because of what he did
last week because juju smith schuster
lit the fuse on a bomb that the browns
didn't even know was there at a time
when the browns were teetering on the
brink with all these covet issues
they're not going to have a coach how in
the hell are they going to win what are
we going to do he gave them with with
one sentence the browns is the browns he
gave them
the ultimate diversion the ultimate way
to snap out of whatever funk they were
in it's very easy to think last week
we're just done it's over that's it it's
hap it's not happening it's not gonna
happen it's not hey we are it was our
year to get to the playoffs it's not our
year to advance thanks to juju smith
schuster and i'm sorry somebody's to say
this to him this enabling of behavior
that undermines the interest of the team
has to end in pittsburgh whether it's
dancing on the logo which finally ended
or saying things that unnecessarily
motivate the opponent the browns is the
browns
why
and uh juju's to go
i i i get it i mean i'm it's hard to
argue that certainly there's no need for
it you're right i mean it gave them a
little extra incentive
uh it's it's it's playing a dangerous
game that way it does it does motivate
other football teams so uh i hear you
there all the way and did i see a video
last night of like
him doing a tick-tock dance on the field
late in the football game did you see
that yes yeah yes right yes and it looks
like i honestly on the video it looked
like the brown sideline was probably
saying something to him
at the end of the game the competitive
part was over and they were like
probably
to me it looked like they were like hey
you're not tick-tock dancing now and he
looked over them and did a dance real
quick or something but either way it's
just a little immature he's gotta gotta
stop that um
javon wims wide receiver of chicago
bears will be my second pick for the
goat draft
in a game where
offense was going to be an issue points
were going to be hard against that great
saints defense the chicago bears needed
every
possible opportunity to make a play they
needed to come through and make it and
then
matt nagy and company dial up a great
trick play
you know toss it to the right toss it
back to trubisky was that receiver kind
of like a reverse and now he's gonna
throw the ball a deep post down the
middle of the field the game seven
nothing saints but the bears defense is
playing pretty good you could see they
got a good feel
man can they score some points and just
keep the pressure on the saints wide
open perfect throughout pass by mr
trubisky
and wims
whiffed it didn't even i don't think he
even got a hand on it it literally went
right through the bread basket right
mike and uh that was a big moment in the
game just to give chicago a little
confidence on the offensive side of the
ball
and and the way it was unfolding and
it's one of those moments where
if you're a saints fan you're saying oh
blepo blepo bleep because you see it
coming right and then all of a sudden
trubisky ends up with the ball
after he had split out wide to the right
right and he fires that thing and it's a
thing of beauty and it's gonna be seven
to seven and all and here we go again
saints right here we go again and he
drops the damn ball that just took all
the air out of the balloon for the bears
and it felt like they were just kind of
trying to run in mud after that
offensively they had the play and and
you know how this goes all week long
they're excited about it they went out
on the practice field all this is going
to be great and they're talking about it
hey when are we using that play oh when
are we going to use that play oh here it
comes here it comes shh wait wait wait
oh
it gets it just
you're done how do you recover from that
and obviously we saw the bears don't
recover from that all right next one for
me
hmm
uh um i can't believe i'm so well i'll
go ahead and take derrick henry derrick
henry's on the board i mean he'll say it
he'll admit it
he had 40 rushing yards he had a long of
eight he didn't get it done when you
have morphed into jim brown you've got
to play like jim brown with the season
on the line and even though as we talked
yesterday the ravens had a great plan to
get to him and knock him down before he
could do damage you still got to find a
way to do damage if you're the guy you
create this huge expectation
and then when the team needs it most
it just disappears 18 carries for 40
yards are you kidding me so i love derek
henry he's a hall of famer he could
probably have another 2 000 yard season
in his career but you got to show up in
the postseason he did it last year and
he didn't this year yeah it was a tough
day no doubt about it i mean he's a
special football player you know we
talked about it yesterday though he
needs a little room to get you know the
engine revved and get going and that's
where you know the titans office of line
let them down a little bit too they were
dominated they really were that that
ravens d-line was possessed and kicked
their butt um
gosh
yeah you know what i'm you're smirking i
know what you're smirking at
i i mean i'm not smirking at anything i
nfl referees i'm taking the nfl referees
this is a whole the whole of them
all of them the every ones who had
nothing to do with ever i don't know
because i can't remember all their names
but every game had a disaster moment
every game and throughout the weekend
there was this issue i mean whether it
was you know the bad job reviewing the
zach baskill fumble and the colts game
you know the just the longevity of some
of the reviews the dead moments of just
referees having conversations in the
field the reviewing of plays where i
can't even remember right now off the
top of my head there was a guy laying on
the ground for six seconds and the ball
got stripped out what game was that and
we went to review to see if it was a
fumble he literally was on the ground
took a nap
woke up took another nap and then he
fumbled it was cam acres in the seahawks
game that's what it was it was the rams
running back he was on the ground for
four seconds somebody pulled it out we
ran around the field the referees never
blew the whistle we went to a commercial
break to review
stuff where i just go are we watching
the game referees or are we just sipping
pina coladas and having a good time
i thought it was a disaster of a weekend
everything so i'm taking them all sorry
well i i i i don't disagree with you
they've got to step it up they've got to
get it done and look it's it's very
simple it is sky judge
but they don't want to spend the money
for sky judge because they don't see the
incremental benefit
arising from the cost that would be
devoted to it and this is one of the
problems with the nfl this isn't
something i'm making up people
in
the atmosphere will tell me this and
this is where it's come from people look
at it and say look at all the money we
pay to this person this person this
person this person why do they not
properly value these key functions
that's what dean blandino said himself
sure a couple of years ago after he left
they don't value the position of senior
vp of officiating it's one of the most
important positions in the league office
why do you not properly value it all
right get the sky judge and things like
this won't happen last one for me i hate
to do this one i hate to do it but
russell wilson
what let russ cook
what was and i know the rams have a
great defense i know i know the rams
have a great defense but
patrick mahomes would shred the rams
defensive given the chance you know we
saw early in the season russell wilson
kind of barged his way into
hey you know don't forget about me when
you talk about patrick holmes and aaron
rodgers and it all fell apart it all
fell apart he wanted to have the chance
to be the straw that stirs the drink and
uh the the straws the straws missed the
the glass chris yeah no well he did not
play his best football in the last five
six weeks of the year there's no doubt
about that you know i i certainly you
can play some blame on him i i also i
think brian schottenheimer could be in
that a little bit too but just lack of
creativity and giving them some more
chances for plays in the past game but i
understand the rust criticism
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports